[Music]
hello and welcome to the breakdown
studio live
i'm woman grandmaster dina bailinkaya
and i'm grandmaster ernest energy
hello we are here to bring you
some of the most exciting games of the
round eight
of the candidates tournament and will be
joining you live
every round to look at the most decisive
games
as they unfold chess is generally a very
deep
game but we love it so much so we're
going to make the show
sharp and fun and exciting and going
through
all this game together with with this
fine experience
we'll be also joined by some legendary
grand masters
who will share with us their
perspectives on one of the biggest year
chess
event yes actually who is our guest for
today you know
shall we keep it as a secret uh give me
some hint
well this is the world world
challenger for for the title former
world challenger
of 2016. also he keeps a record of being
the youngest
gm uh in the world that's right
he's also a world rabbit and blitz
champion
yes so should we say his name or maybe
he don't need even to say it
well he for sure doesn't need any
any um any special um
introduction introduction that's the
word thank you very much
okay so let's keep it a secret for us
yeah let's give it a little secret
before we will come to our guest i wanna
sit i wanna
say that today is very tough round uh
two games is still going and uh
one of the game which is definitely the
most beautiful game of today's round is
the game fabiano quran against uh maxim
vashir
graph it was very sharp game we will
come deep to that game later but
right now i would like to to say that
there is a position where karana still
tried to convert his advantage he has a
rook against knight
but position is objectively drawish so
if maxine will do everything right
we expect that the game will finish in a
troll and about the second game there is
a
clash between two russian grin masters
kirill alexeyenka
and alexander grishouk the game's still
ongoing uh
it seems like alexander trying to to put
maximum pressure on kirill but
uh kirill position is very very solid
and also
we expect that the game should finish in
intro today
what do you think about such long games
in the first round
it's it's very special um of course for
all of them it is the first
over the world game real game that they
are playing touching the
wooden pieces and um i guess
it might be it might be it might
actually feel kind of unnatural i would
even say
but in any case these are very very
experienced players so i'm pretty sure
they won't have any problem with that
and
before we dive into the action
i suggest we take a look at what
happened last year in jakartanburg
just over a year ago when the global
pandemic was taking over
the candidates tournament held in the
russian city victorinberg
was one of the last few big sporting
events before the lockdown
and it should probably go down in
history as the longest chess event ever
as it kicked off on march 17th 2020 and
is still underway
the competition was put on hold halfway
through due to safety reasons as russia
closed the borders
it was yanni bomnshire who got off to a
powerful and confident start with
three draws and three wins in the first
six games
but then he was outplayed in style by
maxine vashey la grav with the two
sharing the lead
after seven rounds now a year on the
planet's toughest chess players are
finally back at it
with the same mission as the competition
has just resumed today
and we are now privileged to present you
with some of the sharpest minds in the
world
who are back to the capital of the euros
they're the magnificent eight
but there will only be one in the end
[Music]
the next man to take on the king of the
hill world champion
magnus carson
we have just seen what happened a year
ago when the tournament
got postponed since russia ban
all the flights and uh right now we are
ready to join our guest we are ready to
join
mr sergey karakin here in our studio
hello hello sir it's a privilege to have
you how are you
very good i'm very glad to see you and
it's a privilege to have you here
in our show uh yes
uh tell us the secret where are you now
in which city i'm in moscow but right
now
i'm i am in the restaurant in the moscow
city
would you like to join us for an
interview as well
no thank you so much
it seems like sergey prepared very well
so you got us
a supporter okay
well um first game day
are you surprised with with the results
how did you you mean you mean the
results of today
sorry yes did you feel bored today
uh no no i didn't feel bored i was i was
actually
very very curious
how deep uh will be the preparation of
the players because
because they prepared for for one year
against each other
and it's like huge amount of time so i
was hoping to get
some novelties some new ideas and
actually we have seen a
very very interesting idea of fabiana
caruana
and he is probably winning with some
luck but anyway
anyway it will be a hugely important
game if he wins it
and and also we have seen that that giri
played
unusual opening opening for him so
there are actually a lot of interesting
things happened today
yes it is hard even to imagine what what
the
is what does it mean to prepare one year
but uh how do you think what
uh give us your thoughts uh uh for whom
this
break was good for some of the
participants uh
who prepared better for the tournament
what is your opinion
well it's hard to say uh of course uh
the
correct answer we can give only after
the end of the tournament
but at the same time i see that fabiano
is probably in a good form because he
prepared a great novelty
great new idea and i remember that
last year he was in a very bad form so
uh probably for him the break was very
good
and for for um others now it's just
to to too
early to say i don't know
yes also i would like to ask uh this is
of course uh difficult for the chess
player to have a such break
i i can imagine that probably it was the
longest break from
uh live games in your in your chess
career also
please uh please describe
how did you manage to build your
training routine during all this period
how was it oh well it was
it was personally for me very difficult
uh
from the from one point of view because
i didn't have tournaments and
i was very much used to go from one
tournament to another from
one training session to another but then
somehow i spent
a lot of time with with my family with
my kids with my wife and
it was all also very important because
before the pandemics started i was
traveling for
too much and so i needed this time with
my family
and and then later on somehow i started
to feel that
the tournaments will come very soon and
i knew that i will play in the super
final so i decided to make
few training sessions and and after that
somehow i started to feel that okay i'm
ready let's try
to play in a tournament uh i
i i played very interesting chess in the
super final i won five
games out of 10 or something
and it was very nice and how did you
feel on
the first round of uh this russian super
final
touching the the wooden pieces again
yeah yeah it was very unusual because i
didn't play
exactly one year i didn't play so
no practice uh of course i played into
internet tournaments but it's completely
different feelings
uh i was very very hungry for for
for the real chess and it was very
important for me to start well
and after i won my first game in the
super final i
i already thought that okay at least
at least one game is good and let's
let's go on nice very nice approach
indeed
it sounds like you have a long vacation
before you get a tournament in your
schedule
is it right i mean it's that it's very
hard to make a real training sessions
before you see that okay
next month i will have a tournament and
you know the opponents and you start to
prepare
before that it's very hard yes yes it
it's really very hard when you don't
know when is your next tournament and
i remember that before when i had a
break like two months
it was already huge break for me but
this time it was one year
and it was really difficult to force
yourself to train chess
but at the same time i i did a lot of
nice things i i made a lot of
sports things so not only chess and
it was also very important for my form
for my
feelings and so i i didn't lose
this time somehow i felt like i spent a
good year anyway
and regarding the candidates who do you
think
could benefit the most from this break
among the candidates
it's really hard to see to say but
i felt like it's not only uh
jan and vashir uh are
competing against each other because
there are also few players who have
50 score who can also
try to win the tournament and i
i was mostly thinking about giri about
the
shook and about fabiano
so who is your favorite sergey
you know them very well you played with
them many games and can you
uh okay yeah chan you the chance
to name the player which uh chances of
whom you consider
as highers i think that the highest
chances
have
but i feel like i feel like
fabiano will do his best and he is
very very dangerous in this tournament
i'm sure that he prepared very well
so we expect uh according to your
prognosis that
there is there will be a race between
caruana and nipponishi
uh it it it might be like this uh
because i really believe that fabiano is
very dangerous
uh-huh okay and have you been helping
out
any of them any of these candidates
i cannot say this information it's a
secret
this this is something we expected after
the tournament
yes but maybe you can tell us in
generally
yes or no don't don't tell the names
just keep it as a joker you know well i
uh i was speaking with different players
for some time and i was giving them
some kind of advices according to my
experience because i played three
candidates and
with a good results but but basically i
wasn't
in a deep deep preparation with anybody
okay we also have a more general
question for you sir gay
uh nowadays we will see new new things
happening in the chess world i'm talking
about uh a lot of uh
coverage uh some some new or
new ideas coming how do you think
what is the future uh of the
chess as a commercial sport uh i mean
uh to be successful as a commercial uh
in the industry uh how do you feel
is it race now or going down
uh i feel like uh it's possible
uh it's possible to find the new
sponsors and new contracts and
uh and cheers can be
can be on tv actually and i remember
that we had a very
successful experience when we played
this armageddon
tournament when when we all had this
i don't know how to say in english
and uh and so when we played the
uh the the
uh uh uh audience
they could see how uh
they could see uh our pulse and what
what i was
thinking about it is good or not the
position
yes very interesting uh we also
uh wanted to ask you about today's game
yeah but before we
go there let us um let us there are
still
some of the questions we prepared um
looking at the list of the participants
in
in your opinion are there some players
that
uh should have
been there but just got unlucky and
didn't manage to
to be selected of course it's me
okay i'm joking it is timor
who who actually was there but
by some some conflict he didn't
he's not playing but of course it's very
unfair that he's not playing
and also i can also admit that
that wesley saw is one of the best
players now
that's for sure and he's not playing
maybe
i would say it's a little bit pity but
but anyways
there are only eight players and
it's impossible to comfortable
fair enough and as someone who played
against
carlson what would be your advice to the
winner of this tournament
whoever it may be
well my advice that carlson is also a
human and yeah
and it's possible to win you have to
believe it
you and you have to wear very very well
uh
it's for sure okay
and not only yes but also also
you have to be ready mentally
to play against world champion it's also
important it's interesting that you
point in this
exactly point can you uh
share the secret with us what what what
exactly what
uh what what is it exactly to be ready
mentally
to play this much uh what is it exactly
how it is i don't know maybe you look to
the mirror every day in the morning and
say oh
i am tyson i will be
i think that for the different
players it it might be a different
advice because
somebody believes that you you need
some uh some help from from professional
uh uh
some mental help some
some of the players needs maybe support
from the family from
from the wife from the kids i don't know
so it really depends
and somebody needs the support from the
from the coaches
because i know for example from my
experience when i won
a candidate's tournament and then later
on i played the match
i i had with myself vladimir putin and
here
he is somehow gave me a
a a a lot of
a lot of motivation a lot of support and
it was
very very important so it was not only
about chess
so do you think nepo is in good hands
uh i'm sure that he's in a good sense
and
i know that vladimir putin is helping
him
very very well yes we also would like to
ask you a
few fiances about
the game i think it's the main game of
today's carolina uh against rochelle
graph
i i know that you played this line with
white also so
uh what what can you say about this game
what was the critical moment because it
seems like vashir found all the best
move
to keep the equality
you know yeah well somehow it was a
strange feeling because
uh because rasheed played played
played well but but he didn't play rook
a7
later on uh later on because this
this uh all he played fine but he didn't
play
uh i mean he didn't poke his rock he was
afraid
maybe of some tactics but but uh
but it was nothing special and i'm sure
that he would make a draw without
any big problems after okay seven but he
decided to give up the room
and it was it was very important i
believe later on he had a draw but
it was very difficult for the human to
defend in this position because there
are
there are many traps and it was it was
difficult
okay right the game is still continuous
right now but uh
about this same game uh you know
yes yeah but this is
this is already completely winning
unfortunately unfortunately what is
winning
i always thought that uh it's very
important when the night uh
which position takes a night because if
the knight can attack power
uh-huh
he made a big mistake when he he allowed
white's king to come to the h5
and with a white king on h5 it's winning
and and with the black skink on g6
he could make a draw but what should be
a plan for white how white should
win this position okay
first of all first of all i think that
he resigned actually
after king g6 but
but also i think that after king e6 king
g7
and next move is rook five and they just
uh it's just winning isn't it okay so
when
when we had a conversation with sergey
the game was just finished and uh
yeah the key is already on g6 but there
is no
result yet uh on the on the website
you should be right though yeah so this
is a big uh a big result for today and
this is just exactly what you just uh
announced it i can say that you
said that caruana is going to be one of
the racers
very very dangerous
yes so this the same game is definitely
here
bashir had a chance to survive but it's
difficult to defend especially after
such a start
yes he had a difficult opening he had to
defend immediately after the
the first moves they made and finally he
collapsed
okay so uh
what about others games sergey did you
find something
interesting in other games well i
uh i think the the interesting game is
uh
alexander against gretchen and actually
i don't know if it's still going
it is still going on in there it is yeah
all right it's probably it's probably
winning for white yeah
even well i i i was very surprised by
the opening choice of alexander because
i thought that in this line they can
only hope for the draw
but in fact he it was also
i think a very very deep preparation by
by alexander and he
got very very good position with black
and
then he was playing on win i'm sure
him that he tried to win but somehow
maybe
in the time travel and and also after
after that
note he didn't make a draw but
in fact it wasn't so much difficult i
mean the position was
was rubbish and
uh there is one more thing you had the
very impressive win in candidate
tournaments when you
won the last game against caruana and
right now uh yanni palmishi is still the
leader and
also karana is going only half point
behind
him what can you say for the leaders how
they should play
is it possible to keep leading you know
don't
i don't know maybe control the situation
what is the best strategy on your
opinion for the players
who is leading right now what we should
expect from them
is to win i mean i mean
it's really hard to say because
[Music]
every game is very important and there
are only six
games left and uh uh
it's very important first of all not to
lose but also some
at some points you have to take uh some
risk because you also need to win
and uh in the games
in the games against fabian carolina
just
sacrifice rook on d5 it's the best way
you can play against him
yes this was the brilliance game and
once you
qualify once you when the candidates uh
what what does it uh feel like
and uh how is the preparation should be
going
uh in order to prepare for the world
championship match
how did they prepare to uh tomorrow you
know sorry maybe not
all of your secrets obviously but um
how different is the preparation to the
world championship match
compared to the candidates or any other
championship
well it was uh personally for me it was
completely different because
i had six months and i had only one
player
against whom you have to prepare of
course he's a
great world champion but i mean he is
just one player it's not a
seven players so so it was
it was fine i i learned almost all
of his games i looked almost
all the openings he played
i made a big preparation
of um in which
kind of positions he is good in which he
is better and
which he is not why he is winning why he
is losing why
he makes a draw i mean i i studied him
very well and
my my coaches also helped me a lot so it
was
it was uh it was of course uh also very
much about
the openings but not only not only
yes and there is a another idea what i
have is uh about iketerymurk are you
going to go there maybe to cheer up
someone and uh just
well actually i was going to come i was
going to go there
but in fact i i have
my own tournament very soon i'll play in
this magnus carlson tour
in a few days also so i i decided to
stay in moscow to prepare
a little bit and to be with my friends
with my family so
i will not go to ekaterinburg but i am
following
the event very very deeply all right
sergey we
shall not perhaps keep you busy for
too long that was such a pleasure having
you
here with us yes thank you thank you
very much thank you it seems
nice to speak with you and nice
nice to see you and have a successful
tournament beat the magnus
thank you thank you very much have a
good comments and have a
good days thank you thank you
bye thank you wow
what a guest what did you find the most
exciting about uh sergey's inside
cernesto
uh sir gabriel was always
you can say magic player on my opinion
because he have a very special thing you
know
during his career especially when he was
getting these achievements as winning
the candidate tournaments playing the
match against magnus he played like
some regular tournaments on one level
it's usually a bit lower and suddenly on
the tournament like candidates world cup
he's showing just incredible power
uh you know we even was saying between
our grandmasters that he is
like like a changing you know become
like a kraken that no one can stop him
and this is
very special i think about him so in the
very uh
important moment of the tournaments or
the chess career he just
changing completely and showing
extremely
extremely high level of play of course
uh i'm talking about level for him i
mean he's generally a very strong player
with a lot of achievements and
i'm very glad that we start our show
today with him with a player who have
this experience playing candidates
playing the world championship patch
knows all the players and of course this
is very insightful
for us yeah and that is the part of our
show
every round will be different but uh we
will be covering
all of them and we will have the guests
and
even though they will be different they
will be
outstanding and special and
you will be surprised for sure
yes okay so i suggest to look on what is
going on really uh first i suggest to
check
is it really that uh for sure like
already resigned because this
can be a very important news for us
before we will continue
let me have a look well karana beated
the schilograph
this is true and alexinka is still shown
to be winning
against grishok yeah the game is still
going on according to the um
to the live broadcast okay so
then i suggest to start with the game
karwana
against marshall lagrave
okay just a moment i will
let us bring the game yes uh okay
the game started uh first uh before
before we will continue
uh rasheela graph is a player who plays
uh many of the same openings
uh with white uh with black pieces uh
only four he
has always played sicilian and this is
another system is the most
the most sharp opening in in in the
theory of chess
and uh um my very favorite opening
yes and uh i can imagine
the the point of caruana that he more or
less knew what is going on
but the danger of maxim that he knows
this position
extremely well he know everything he has
a very big team of preparation and he
played it uh
i don't know hundreds of games in these
systems so it is very difficult to find
any surprise against him but what we can
see that from the beginning
the first fabiano choose the most
sharp line in this nether neither is
sharp but
caruana also choose the most sharp
variation of this system the sharpest
approach
yes so if you want try
then the most spicy dish
in chess so here here we have it this is
the dish
yes okay bishop g5 is a famous line the
most sharp players of all chess history
played
this system it was uh michael tal and
all all let's say attacking players just
used to play this line e6 f4
so we quickly go through the openings uh
this is um
uh the pound sacrifice white immediately
sacrifice a pawn
and this is so called poison pound
sacrifice because consider
when this line was uh find out all the
players consider it it is
wrong to take this pawn for black so
that's why it have a name poison pawn
variation uh this is still theory i
should say that uh till the middle of 16
this is
was all known for both of players
because uh
maxim already played this position
before
he played this position against anish
kiri and then they made a draw
and in this position karana made
the move which is not novelty yet he
plays his three
but this is a rare move already and
after this moment
maksim started to sink so i
not sure if he was surprised at all or
maybe
he tried to to recall his lines but
anyway he starts thinking
and actually i should say that this is
part of of the game these days
that players usually more or less know
how they start the game
and this is the first phase of their
fight
this is some kind of a psychological
psychological war between two of them
who will be the first to be yes so to be
surprised even though as you you're
right you mention it
uh it could be also just checking yeah
he he knows what he does but
like the the grishock style let's take
our time when though we know what we
want to do
yes this is uh this is you never know
and actually the players also
uh not only thinking about chess moves
they also think what my opponents think
and what i want him to make
uh thinking about the situation and this
is uh this is quite deep and
and interesting he choose the bishop c5
absolutely normal move and next uh
bishop g325 uh the real novelty come
comes on move 17 and actually for me
this was quite shocking move
despite the computer showing as one of
the possibility but still i always
surprised a lot when we just put our
piece
under attack oh wow what a beautiful
move indeed
yes you can see that the bishop is not
defending
of any pieces he has no defense so
washer simply took the bishop
yes but asking the question and what's
next
yes you know such moves usually make a
small kids when they just start playing
they see the queen
they want to take the queen and they
tried tries all the ways to attack but
of course
when such a grandmaster make it you
don't expect him to have a blunder
and next move is also very very
beautiful after queen takes c4 the point
was to play bishop d6
of course it's very difficult to make
such move without preparation obviously
that caruana prepared
all this idea uh now there is many
threats uh
around the black king the main point is
that black king cannot
uh go to the safe place here black
simply can't cast cannot castle right
now
yeah that's true and bishop takes this
six doesn't work because of nine takes
is six and this would be
a double attack worth work as everyone
knows
and if we count the material situation
we can see that my
maxim have right now extra piece and
three pounds
so uh this is extremely short start
because
this advantage is usually enough for win
even two pounds is very big but
karana sacrifices peace and three pounds
uh so
what for how do you sing dina well there
must be something concrete and
as you mentioned bishop takes this is
not possible castling is not possible
either so just
by looking at these pieces even though
you say they're like extra pieces
uh rook on the eight knight on b8 and
bishop on c8 black cannot move them i
th the only possibility i would say is
knight c6 does that work for black
but in in either way before we continue
it is true that there is some kind of
compensation
here the question is what it is and uh
how to proceed actually the terrible
terrific
threat is bishop takes e5 and then
knight goes to d6 so if
you try 96. this one is nice knight
bishop takes c5
i can show it yes so it was your
question what happens if not go to c6
bishop takes to c5 and this is
immediately winning for white
because now knight d6 is a just killing
threat
uh yeah you're absolutely right the main
point of this sacrifice is that the king
is still on the center
and uh what black simply don't have time
to castle and
all the pieces is on the corner of the
boards so this is
also you know if we compare chess to
life it is like
time is more important than material yes
that is
this position shows this fight between
time and material material so what do
you prefer you
actually what will you prefer to have a
i don't know
a few millions of dollars in your bank
account or to have
a few more years of your life well i
guess
there is nothing there is nothing to
think about you if you have
millions on your bank account and you
die tomorrow what is
all about but yes the point is here um
even all the pawns cannot move right so
even if i move the pawns even if i do
not
do do not play knight c6 there is still
this bishop
c5 threat knight takes knight takes and
then knight d6 so yes
what what should black do here how to
connect actually
found absolutely the best defense here
he just
sacrificed his bishop but change
more pieces instead so knight of six is
absolutely unnecessary move here
and now bishop c5 is not possible
anymore because knight will take on
e4 so he will want to change this very
dangerous knight
so this is what he's going to do that's
why that's why karana played knight
takes c5
obviously he wants to avoid the changes
and this is so amusing you know to look
at the evaluation bar
on your left where you have an
absolute equality yes so this is
how computers help us to to go more deep
in the chess positions
and and after 95 the the father moves
are also quite forced
so black uh need to to change
as much pc as possible and this is only
chance to sort to survive so 95
attacking boss
the queen and the pawn on c3 queen e5
uh just a moment okay
yeah this is uh yeah i have i'm gonna
use this
uh yes and here here is another
brilliant moment to come
so obviously that white pieces um are
more active than the black ones
but when you have a piece activity you
need to break through you need to do
something you cannot just waste your
time
because this is your advantage and here
we we have another very nice sacrifice
knight takes e6
uh after xc6 knight xc6 yes
and this is quite uh quite natural what
uh
maxim did here he took queen takes c3 we
will go there but i just want to show
how
the engines keep thinking about such a
situation obviously for the
human being this queen is very dangerous
against the black skink and you cannot
just ignore the situation but you know
can you guess what is the uh the best
suggestion of computer in this position
the most coolest move you can you can
even though the computer suggestion is
just in front of my eyes i will try not
to look there and
pretend i didn't look there before
oh my um i would say
well does knight e7 work if knight
center is queen takes c7
yes yes no yes bishop takes it
basically your queen down okay it
doesn't make any sense
oh my um okay i will not puzzle you much
yeah wait wait okay it's a king move
it's it's a key move for sure so
something like
absolutely crazy king d7 in front of
your rook yes king d7 is also looks
interesting for me but
what after rook takes d5 you're so
mean wait a second there was a check if
there is a check we can
save at least one tempe uh queen h4
check and we do not get checkmate that
on the move after
yeah this is what uh what i wanted to
show you and why i asked this question
because it doesn't work
um i don't know about h4 i guess not
actually um okay i want to show you from
lightning yes
okay actually very nice defense is
knight f6
and this is just ridiculous to play this
move uh what i wanted to show is
uh every chess player is very scary
about such positions
of queen against king yeah there is a
discovered check on the way yes
it's very natural that you try to avoid
this check in any cost you want to run
with the king who
want to make a check instead to want to
cover your king with 97 this is just for
the chess player it's very natural you
cannot think like that you're king
your king is uh under attack and you
know the king for the chess player is
like the most uh it is
the most precious and not just for i
mean for a chess player like as if chess
players were different from other
human beings but it is just the point of
the whole game if your
king gets uh in trouble and eventually
gets checkmated then
you lose the game so you need to take
care of your this yes
and actually the line continue like that
this defense not g5 you can see that
there is no normal move for the king
it will be made immediately and it is
bishop e6
oh wow under two threats like this yes
so you you will not take with a
queen but because then there will be
queen exchange and uh
well let's admit it no attack of queen
swap
off the board but uh there is knight
takes
e6 and now same situation but we now
have this
c8 how does it help us this c8 square uh
it's not about syria we we won a temple
because uh uh
uh it was a temple in your position and
after 96 it's already
suddenly black is winning oh so after
bishop
c bishop b6 the only move is queen take
c6 and play this and this end game uh
with extra pound for black so this is
just pretty brilliant defense but i
wanted to show that position is
extremely crazy that such best players
in the world
karana and maxim for them it's also
difficult and
um also the position is so rich what
they
what they have so maxim choose one plan
but computer shows another plan
we i have another idea you have another
idea so i so much like such a situation
on the board when
every player can choose what he likes so
this game is
is very very rich on possibilities
and summarizing do you think this bishop
c4 was a move found on the board or it
was some kind of
recalling and old preparation uh bishop
c4 is definitely preparation for
fabiano because uh okay c3 he played
quickly and bishops before he played it
quickly but for maxim i don't sure
because he found the best move but maybe
he recalled it so
you know when you're playing as such in
line what what is happening in the in
the player's
mind uh definitely uh looked for
almost i'm i'm sure about that but if
you're
not sure 100 you just cannot play it
immediately
and what you do as professional you
start to to check it
uh check what you remember check how you
should play
and then you spend a lot of time maybe
you don't see everything maybe
don't see any details and that why we
don't know exactly was maxim singing or
maybe he was trying to check his uh his
memory
okay so let's come back uh after um
not tax c6 he took queen takes his three
this is very understandable he decided
to simplify the position and
i i believe this was quite normal move
okay and what we get here
we got this end game where uh might have
a rook
and black have knight and two pounds
frankly i was considering it
not that dangerous for black i quite
surprised that sergey evaluated as a
difficult for defense
but of course this is uh not only about
chess
this is also about psychology so one
player get a chance is he enjoying the
position
he is trying to find new ideas and
second players have to be just very
patient
and keep keep his keep his attention
only on opponent's ideas and this is
very difficult psychologically because
we
we like to create we don't like to to
see how someone is creating
so it's always easier to be the attacker
than the defender
yes yes completely i see your point
and uh it looks like
the of course position position is
better and only white can win but
chances for the draw was always high
even in this position when kirana took
on of 6
and ruined the black's king side and the
chances was
quite high and
frankly next uh next point when they
change this
this bounce uh i mean this this was
this moment after the change dispenses
look for me like it should be
more or less easy draw to be honest
because the knight only five is very
strong
and it is very hard to to break through
for white
let's let's see what happened later
because this was important how uh
how quran finally found a way to win and
this is also what sergey told us
in the interview that it was it was
actually
equal until the moment when uh black
black led white's king to get to age
five
yes okay actually uh the point of this
position is
is all about white king and the best way
of defense
if uh is that if you have a counter play
against g
two pawn and don't land white pieces to
improve
too much uh okay just imagine idiol sit
up
if white would play g4 for example this
is wrong move
95 this is would be immediately very
very
close to draw because it might have
ideal position he attacks g4 square and
and also stopping the
the white king for for coming too close
but of course white is not hiring visji
for
uh and this is what karana was doing he
simply was improving his position
and uh for the very long
period it was uh very drewish also
you see this position this is very quite
uh smart
way of defending that h6 is stopping the
white king from coming to f5
or somewhere all right you know i'm
i feel like i have a deja vu if you see
what i mean
there was some kind of an end game with
the exchange
up for one side recently in the game of
uh
of uh one of the world leaders uh
doesn't
it remind you of something yes actually
this this positions reminds many times
and position uh in here it sounds like
it was um
it was a mainstream some
some months ago i guess we will check
this later and
i remember the game exactly with similar
similar pounds have six against g pounds
it was a game
it was a game of thal actually it was a
famous end game
uh and actually he he drew that game
there was one more
we will see that later on okay so
uh the plan how how karana finally
managed to win it was
the king manure to h5 and this is what
sergey told told to us so you can see
that
there was many moves when caruana
couldn't improve his position
and the key moment come come come here
uh then the move knight g8 i believe was
not accurate after which the knight is
too passive
and now we see that after king g4 king
is coming to h5
and this has become already more
difficult for for black to defend
because if the king come to h6 there is
more chances to
to push back uh the black pieces
yes and uh i think we should go to the
to the final position do we have it can
you can it can you tell me
yes let me let me tell you the moves yes
please
uh we when we started our stream uh the
game was continued
and uh during our conversation uh we
still get to make
much more moves so we just share it with
you
by the way um we already have a result
in alexandria versus grishop gaming
alexandre
but we'll get to this one later yes okay
just tell me a few moves yes so what was
the last move you had
73 let me update you so move number 73
g4 is on the board then it was well
simply there there was not much of the
say you know
there was a key five kingdom six and
that's it
yeah but what is this threat can you
guess why it's lost let us have a look
let us make this two
king e5 king g6 oh
this is actually a mistake i mean yes
it was already it was already about
position obviously but this king e5
actually
makes it even worse just before if you
go back
if you go after g4 yes so it looks like
one mistake okay position is difficult
anyway
uh i will show what what is the problem
first of all you need to make some move
you cannot
you cannot wait so just imagine that he
will not let the king to come to e6 yes
and now here knight is attacking g6 so
king cannot go to g6
uh uh king i i will go king is six uh
just imagine women five just do some
random moves
one and now my king has come to g7 and
black simply cannot wait anymore and so
i
everything is okay for me but i i i
should not move if i could only jump at
you
at the same place or simply say i do not
want to move make your your second move
but unfortunately this is not possible
in chess
yes and uh so so what what is the
problem why maxine resigned because he
will lose his f pound anyway
and without this pawn it is easily win
for white yes that's true
yeah so what uh okay so what can we say
about this game
oh wow this is for sure may i say
the most exciting game of the round yes
it is very strong novelty but more what
i like it is very brave game because
white
sacrificed it sacrificed peace three
pounds
in a very very sharp position and
actually later caruana pushed
very hard and maxim didn't manage to to
defend
so this is quite yeah this part is
shocking start
because okay everybody was talking that
maxim actually you know he gave an
interview that he prepared very well and
going to win this event and just
just round one and okay he's already not
a leader anymore
yeah that is a hard one uh shall we
shall we show now
alexandria game this is one more
decisive game resultative game yes white
one alexandre one
who was by the way um the
the outsider of the of the event and now
he joins the leaders
he will now have 203 and a half as um
as grishouk yes right so um
yeah i think this is uh uh this is game
um
left uh unusual feelings uh to me uh
first of all i agree with sergey that it
is unusual choice for
um alexander krishuk he is not famous to
play in french defense
and also he uh choose the line uh we can
see again that
that black is taking pawn on b2 and you
see so maybe we can
give an advice to our viewers don't take
the boundaries don't take the poison
pawns
do not do that that that's a trap do not
believe your opponents
yes okay so uh
objectively speaking this is very very
long theoretical line is going right
here so this is famous sacrifice uh once
again this is preparation of the players
uh what is the point of this position uh
why light's position looks like
winning for me when i saw this line the
first time strategically i totally agree
with you look at this rook look at this
bishop
the rook on h8 uh the bishop on the fate
the king in the center
oh god that that scares me and the
bishop the french bishop
it's uh yeah but okay
once again the evaluation is equal so
ernesto
there must be something tell us yes uh
so
we can divide the position on few
factors we can say that white
black bounce is just very good uh all
bounced
defends each other and white have a
weakness on c2 this is
the reason number one second we can see
that if the knight uh
knight on six on c3 can be attacked one
day so you cannot uh
stay with your knight on c3 for the long
time but if you will try to regroup
this night let us where would you like
to put tonight
uh yes i would like to show this idea
jurgen c8
yes okay computer cannot sing like me
okay and yeah this is his biggest
weakness yes
and i cannot sing like him and this is
my biggest weakness
this is your biggest
weight achievement
okay this is your biggest strength i get
it
thanks okay so if we if if white would
remove the knight from c3 then the
bishop will come to b5 so it will be no
longer a
big bishop and this is a point uh why
this position looks scary and winning
for white because
white have rook on b7 and bishop on d4
all the pieces is extremely uh active
but nowadays the players can analyze
this position in deep
and uh it's already well known that
white is not winning here there is no
immediate list
strike so usually the game going quite
slow so
black finish in development queen d8
bishop 7 castle short
and then the game continues like that so
the planet is 28 and the bishop
yes bishop bishop out and then the king
castle and then
yeah well so three moves that black
needs in order to
to get uh his life back yes okay it
sounds like too much for the chess point
of view but
uh this line is is quite solid and
actually nakamura is playing played this
line not in the in a single game any
permission player this line
so it is topical line or the french
defense okay
first move is queen h4 the idea of this
move is uh
the main the main answer of white is
usually bishop f2 queen d8 and then
black goes to this plane bishop is seven
castle short and uh
and playing more or less normal position
i also heard recently the term for such
a
strategic a very nice strategical
pattern it is called a
okay i'm trying to recall it is um
a disappearing move
what is it uh you you actually want to
play rook
queen d8 okay but before doing that you
do a move
which will disappear for you once you
like just a move after but
it will actually change something for
your opening it will force him
to to put his piece on on a
weaker spot which is here bishop f2
and then queen h4 queen h8
and right now you see there is nothing
that changed for black but
this is the the difference so it is a
very interesting maneuver you know when
you for example you want to develop your
bishop and you put it like
you want to develop to e6 but then you
put it to g4
you attack he must defend something like
bishop e2 and then bishop back to e6 so
it is a very nice pattern that i would
recommend to our viewers to actually
take into consideration for their games
yeah this is very nice
i will i will i will also try to use it
in my games
you're welcome okay uh so um
this is how the game generally should
continue so bishop f2 is a main move
still but in this game kirill tried to
play queen f2
which is a quite modest decision because
uh
we just described these positions that
might have a very strong activity but
when you change the queens the activity
already not that strong so it's not that
dangerous for black
and actually this is what happened in
the game after queen takes bishop e7
uh quite quickly black got a very
comfortable position
uh bishop d8 is preparation for the
castle short so he want to remove his
bishop from the seventh rank and then
castle short and this is actually what
is going on
and the rook is uh is pushed back this
is this is actually an amazing
achievement for black because uh
well white has no no joker anymore
yes and somewhere here uh frankly i was
already thought that uh
it is already black who will try to to
push push something and
actually grishak tried tried that
so c4 is idea to to remove this weak
pawn
you remember we were talking about that
and uh
wait a second this this is something
that actually um
[Music]
that is actually pretty surprising for
me because when you when you push c4
strategically it's it might not be the
that
that brilliant because the bishop wishes
was supposed to be the
one or one of the biggest pieces of
black will now become active but as you
say
chess is about um comparing you have
millions of different strategical ideas
and you need to to compare them
so here the importance of uh getting rid
of the weak c
four pawn as you say is more important
than they just the opening the bishop
and once again the bishop will go
later on to b5 yes uh
so uh this is uh this is the moment when
on my opinion alexander started to play
for equality so he decided okay i didn't
get advantage out of the opening so it
is
very important to keep the situation
under control and c4 this is a move
which shows that his mod
f6 is uh showing another mode as you can
imagine
alexander definitely is trying to
complicate the matters because when you
have the bishops you
should try to open as much lines uh as
you can and also we can see that
white king is on on the center and that
this is a possibility that in the future
opening for the lines in the center can
can cause the problem for the white king
even though uh we are already in the
endgame and usually
uh one should not be threatened of uh of
getting checkmated or attacked
for his king when he's in the end game
but here once again too many pieces
yes okay so let's quickly go what
happened after that so this is
strategical points of this game
uh actually both players quite uh played
quite good game
and the position was balanced for the
very very long time
so that's why we will not stop uh too
deep
on the moment we will come directly to
the uh
to the moment when um got uh got
the material advantage so you can see
that the game become more sharp
the e5 pound is strong and this rebound
is strong so both players trying to
to make it work uh and also you you see
that white king is quite
in dangerous position just easily can we
imagine bishop g5 d2 and uh
this will be nothing easy for for white
but uh this uh bishop on the six and
pound only five is
generally not worse than the rooks and
this is actually what uh
uh alexandra showed in in this game
yes this bishop on d6 is in an
incredible
outpost yes even though the the pile is
genuinely close by the d3 pawn pretty
unnatural
isn't it yes and also i would mention
that king kong g8 is quite passive right
now so
so finally it seems like white have more
possibilities
to improve the position than black and
what
uh the only problem in in the position
is this d3 pawn
and actually what happened is uh that in
some moment alexandra just decided to
get rid of this
this this pound so you see he sacrificed
the
the rook and the take on d3
yeah and this is key point of the game
uh it's hard to evaluate
who is seriously better computer likes
rooks for sure
but i would prefer this bishop because i
don't see how black really can win this
game but i easily can imagine how white
can do in this game
still i wouldn't try this position
against computer for sure
pick up because computer will know how
to place with the rooks
and suddenly so if before before this
move
it is quite clear that more or less
krishuk was trying to complicate the
matters to to make the position more
complicated even even so he didn't
have any advantage but he was trying to
complicate the situation but after this
position he already should be accurate
and finally he he didn't manage to do
that
well for for a human eye this bishop on
d6
and this pawn on e5 look fantastic so
i would definitely agree with uh with
the idea that
the rooks are active but it's the
computer yes and right now it's already
equal right the evaluation
yeah i think at some moment grisha
should just give back this exchange
took the bishop on the six but it's not
easy to find the right moment right now
so he didn't do that
and uh and later this cost caused the
problem to him
yes the key moment was when the pawns uh
go forward and this is already very very
dangerous uh
uh also we were talking with sergey so
we didn't see what was krishna inside
not or not but
finally what happened in the game is
that this pawn
promoted i'm pretty surprised to see
such a deep positional understanding
from a
a young player who doesn't have as much
experience as
his rivals here and they're supposed to
be an underdog in this tournament
yeah actually this is game i think
showing uh the potential
the potential and the strength of kirill
because you see this is quite
deep uh moments in this position to
evaluate
all these details to calculate it
correctly because the game finished in a
very sharp
race when black took the pound and
suggested for white to
go forward with the power 97 so it's
required a lot of
accurate calculation and
and this is was always on my opinion
best
threat of kirill alexian actually we
should introduce him a bit
so he is a a a the youngest participant
of the tournament and a quite surprising
participant
uh he uh got um to this tournament uh
he got the wild card officially but now
the wild card
it's not easy to get this wild card and
you deserve to show very good results
before before this before in the
candidate tournaments
organizers could just nominee any player
they like
if the player meet the conditions that
he's hello
is more than 2700 but nowadays you need
to
to to show very good result or in world
cup or in grand swiss very big
selection tournament and kirill was
surprised and is the best russian player
in this grand swiss selection and
because of that he got this wild card
is true he finished third in in
in in the isle of man the tournament you
you're mentioning and uh
well kill was already known before as
i recall him winning two consecutive
to gordon memorials in saint petersburg
pretty strong
open tournaments and winning them the
two of them in the row
that means something yes and also it was
like his
uh uh 2019 was a year when he just uh
like a rocket you know go higher and
higher and higher and it ended with this
grand swiss event so he's
we can say he's a rising star who just
going forward okay pandemi stopped him a
bit but
we can see that uh the first game of
this
tournament shows that he is going to go
forward once again and this is what he
wish
we wish him yes so so finally the game
uh was over like that so so
he spawned uh he just promoted the pawn
and uh
and that that's how the game finished
let us switch to the next game um yes
okay which one do you prefer yes i think
it's time to look for the
game of chinese player players
this is actually a quite sharp line but
i want to say that the this line was
very interesting even kasparov tried it
with white
uh but uh you see because far if not
even dina balance i tried it uh several
times okay
so you have very attacking style you
know well my favorite move here is
bishop d3 but
if you say so you should not tell this
more sherman it's okay more charming if
you custom
you know sacrifice the pieces
i can play different styles let's see
let's call it like this so this is a
scar just cash defense so
yes uh yes uh very
unusual strategic early positions
usually when we have e45 startup game
both pawns stay in front of each other
and the game is more or less slowly
and this default breakthrough is ideal
just to open the positions immediately
and
to get unbalanced situation so this is
very interesting start
but the line which one how picked
uh it is sharp but it is famous
that the black have enough defense and
uh it is very
it was very likely that the game will
finish in draw after this start so it
was
uh it was uh just a few moves need to
need it from the leader and to make the
draw so let
let's uh let's show let's show the game
yeah it was um
for sure a little bit less exciting oh
yeah it was a move for bishop
really this is this is the one that's
the moment i say that
yeah you didn't play that okay yeah so
the point of the bishop is three so we
force
black to go knight before because queen
e6 is not possible c takes d5 so
knight before is uh the okay more or
less only move bishop b2
bishop g7 and a3 this is an idea so
uh now knight is forced to go to d5 back
and then knight to d2
uh it's important to mention there's a
pin here so c takes d flat is not
possible yes
possible uh so all these theoretical
moves castel castel
rook e8 and the idea of the line shows
the moves queen of three
so now knight is attacked and if you
remove
the knight back for example knight b6
after 94
white have just terrific square on f6
it's horrible so it forced and now black
is forced to sacrifice
the the exchange
uh yes ah okay after move uh
ah it's not uh okay yeah i make it less
you just spoil it you just spoil
something okay
uh so this is a exchange sacrifice once
again but after knight takes c8 the
black have uh just a repetition of the
position the only uh novelty in this
position was
uh the move knight a4 uh this yeah
how many how many um
this piece of sacrifice have we haven't
seen so far
rook exchange in the game uh alexandre
grishoek
peace and game caruana uh against
maximus elegrath a lot of sacrifices
yeah yes and after 94 white king will be
open and uh this is enough to to have a
counter play for the draw so
queen of six is a very accurate move and
after queen b3 it's just a repetition of
the position
i want to remind that there is a rule on
chess maybe someone is joined joined our
stream
and just want to know what is chess
about if the players repeat
the position three times the game is
drawing automatically yes that's true
okay so this was a draw between two
chinese player
players i also should mention that the
there is a rule in this tournament
then when uh a few participants is uh
from the same country
they have to meet each other in the
first round to avoid you know some
suspicious results in the last round so
we can see today that
mahal plays against ding litten and also
alexander playing against grishok
so this is because of that this is
actually pretty um pretty common
practice um
on different chess chess tournaments uh
the
the the best example that uh comes to my
mind is uh music sisters
uh anna and maria always meet in the
first round uh which was the case in the
in the women's grand prix recently and
uh surprisingly
it is always a draw yes okay but what do
you think about this i mean
well uh okay not about sisters of course
yeah but
about about the rule matching uh two
players from
one like who could be i
well i think it's it's it's for sure the
right strategy i
i cannot argue with this one i mean you
never know and uh it is also human for
for for people to yeah who could be
close to
to be considering sometimes well
yeah and also it become even if the all
players are honest
and absolutely trusted you cannot
avoid the situation when others are got
nervous in this situation they start to
suspect each other and this is just bad
so we
avoid this this is very nice way to
avoid this yeah very nice indeed okay
okay so let's uh check now the last game
uh the fourth game of the of today's
round
there was a very nice tweet i i noticed
from anish giri
uh when the game was already finished
and we were still preparing for our
breakdown i guess uh we could bring it
later on
i i won't say what it is about we'll see
the game started with e4 yes
okay so it is uh uh it is sitting in
defense uh so-called
uh okay in russia we call it chile's
variation yes because
it was a a soviet masters from the city
of zillabinsk
which invented this system uh and in
in uh western part of the world
it used to call this version of us
[Music]
uh actually uh eugene is facing as the
creator
of this line he uh declared that this is
the best chest moves
possible in chess oh really yeah he was
saying that this is he found uh the
the best way of play chess so e4 c5 and
uh
exactly all these moves played like this
and that's it yes
this is what this is what he declared
and he was making a lot of researches so
pro
maybe giri finally also made this
conclusion
we should ask him i guess so we will yes
so the point of this system
um that black gives uh
very strong square for the white now
white can use this d5
outpost this is very strong outpost but
as
uh compensation they get awkward
position
of the knight on s3 and also they got
some temples because this knight need to
be
improved and during this period black
will get a better
position for the pieces so all this of
course theoretical positions so the game
all these moves was quite famous and
here uh it is a critical
moment because the most uh sharp
variation starts
when white plays a4 b takes a 4 not
not c2 b4 and this is all how it started
even there is a
sacrifices possible once again after
bishop d7 for example
there is one of the land rook takes a4
but
maybe jan was not really prepared
for this choice of giri so he decided to
choose more slow
way of playing g3 castle h4
a3 and the only okay the here the move
he made queen d3 is technically no
novelty but
it did doesn't change much the position
is about equal because
here black have counter play on the king
side with b4 and also
black have the bishop despite it looks
like the bishop is passive but
bishop controls very important square e3
so once you will try to support d5
outpost with 93 this bishop will be
changed and this is actually what
happened in the game
knight uh 97 attacking d5 so this
is trying to exchange this important
knight yes and 93
protecting but uh looks like yes but
they changed
and this position already quite knowing
that this is not
nothing special for white and the
players
just find a way to repeat the moves
because the position was about equal
white
didn't see how to proceed and they
repeated move like that
bishop d1 bishop b6 bishop g4 bishop ps3
bishop d1
well dina so what do you take on
from this round of candidate tournaments
the games were more exciting
that i would have imagined to be honest
uh we had only two draws
only two for for the first round
remember the time we were betting
we said it would be for portrayals for
sure but
no actually not yeah well for the for
the first game
since a year
bishop c4 from um caruana mvl i
i definitely enjoyed this one and also
the fact that
kiril alexandro the the underdog
the the the player who was on the bottom
at the bottom of the of the
tournament won his game and uh
is now well sharing the bottom but it's
not
it's not the the the outsider anymore is
pretty
pretty inspiring to me and what about
you ernesto
i i absolutely agree that bishop c4 is a
very strong novelty from
fabiana i would also mention that
it seems like the players who was
following the leaders
i'm talking about caruana giri they
prepared very well because nepal nisha
had a white pieces but he didn't pose
any problem to giri
and karana just used his his chances
with white pieces maybe if
giri also would have a white pieces we
could see also a different game
so i would mention that i feel that giri
is also prepared very well and
should not forget about his chances also
and
of course uh i'm very excited that it is
decisive and such important decisive
game you know it is uh in some
tournament it is
it is just like a sleepy atmosphere what
i mean
uh players look to each other one is
play playing slowly try to be a great
now the plane slowly try to back red but
when you see around everybody is winning
everything has happened and yeah you
know the players become very angry on
each other because next round i believe
maxine will be very angry oh yeah for
sure yes
yeah so this is this is absolutely
exciting start
maybe it's the best possible we could
expect and also with a very delicious
chess
delicious is the nice word you you've
chosen i like that one
yes and um regarding their
regarding their positions in the
tournament and the
the predictions that we had let us bring
you a tweet of uh of chess.com that was
commented by anish giri a very nice one
i am sure our our viewers would be
would be curious to to have a look at
this one
okay so what was it uh
can you read it or we will see it yeah
our our
our team will bring this to us
so if you are magnus carlsen
which fitted candidates competitor
do you least want to face in
the 2021 world's chess
championship and there were suggested
four different answers fabiano carvanha
yanni pomnishi maxim vashilagraph other
and apparently anish got a little bit
offended by this one
answering on this tweet if you were
watching the show
which website would you look the games
at
chess 24 kasparov chess
leeches or other
okay i guess in one week
he will write on the first button our
show
yeah if you were if you were watching
the candidates uh
which broadcast which breakdown
would you would you put on
and then let's let's take something let
me guess
chess24 chaz.com
leeches or
break down live studio with grand master
ernesto narkief and woman grandmaster
dina bellingkaya
definitely dina i will choose you
doesn't matter on which broadcast you're
going to be
i just realized uh thank you for this
one i just realized there were
four options that i put i didn't put
other but you get the point
nice one okay um let us
um what about tomorrow dina uh what
about tomorrow round
let us look at the standings let us look
at the standings and see
what is waiting for us tomorrow uh
can we see the standings not yet so
that means uh we should uh
yeah we should just just check about
tomorrow round what we have uh tomorrow
is very interesting day
also first of all uh the the game number
one it will be alexander playing against
karana and alexandra will have a white
pieces
i should mention that uh when the
players win the game
they usually feel like uh a wind they
feel inspired
yes and what i can say about alexander
he is not
i don't think that he feels that this is
his time to become a challenger for the
world champion so
his main point i guess is to to get this
experience and also to feel his power
can he play against the best players can
he beat them
so tomorrow i believe this is will be
the most exciting game the most
dangerous for the cafe obviously and
i expect them to be very well
this is from for me it will be the game
number one tomorrow the thinking is
karana
and looks like we are having the
standings finally so
right now uh we
we do not have the results updated yet
do we no this
these are the results of the previous
round but we already know that
maxim lost his game so we have a soul
leader right now we have a soul reader
who is yani pam nishi who drew his game
today
and uh that that you know what
that that reminds me of something last
round
russian super final
yami pony she drew his game in six
moves or no that wasn't that was a very
short game
and just putting it like this well
whatever happens
i just do not want to play the the thai
breaks
our megadon and everything and on the
other side we had sergey karakin our
guest of today
who who fought who had
a super tough super long game
against daniel dubov and lost and
eventually
found himself on the second place which
made uh yanny bonnie she be the leader
this is the same situation
here actually it sounds like a magic for
me you know it
it looks like uh what you described that
you can make a
drawing six move and win the tournament
yes this is a dreaming situation for for
the players who don't like chess but
uh i think for every chess player is
much more uh exciting to win the
tournament
and after after winning an exciting game
okay okay so we have a new standings uh
so dina please
uh please tell us what we have right now
right so um uh yes well
we still have maxime on the position
number one but
we do see that he's uh having four and a
half
so he's on the second place while yanni
pognashin is on the place number two
this is what we oh yes this is what we
see right now on the screen but
do not be do not believe that these are
uh
these are not uh the well
in any case you know yanni bomichi has
five points
he is on the first place
right now is also four and a half uh
giri
have four points four points for gary
yes and uh three and a half should have
uh
team iran and uh
uh grisha closed he's he has a greater
clause to alexian because they both have
three and a half
each yes so one how and dinner and drew
which makes them four as far as i
remember
yes okay so right this makes uh
okay you will correct me in any case if
i'm wrong but for now as far as i
remember let us test my memory
we have nippon initiate five points
yes maxine four and a half karana four
and a half
digloran van hau and uh
yeah you forget about giri and gary
remember i do think that we we're close
very close well actually
we're pretty close to that one yes okay
so let's uh
so finally we know the leaders uh it's
quite obviously that
four players is uh more close to uh
yanipan issue five
caruana and uh maxim have four and a
half and four have giri other players
have less
so and uh about the games for tomorrow
one we already uh announced it it will
be alexander against uh
karana uh another game would be grishok
against nippon nishi
uh this is uh also uh will be very
important game to understand what is
going on in this event because yes
alexander lost today but tomorrow he
will have
white pieces and this is a chance for
him to show what what actually he did
during this year we also
would like to know the answer on this
question this is the question that we
would like to ask to all of them
yes what did you do the whole year and
yeah we do know that chess players
well it's pretty understandable but when
when just the moment when tournaments
got postponed and there was no no
certain information about
when and how it would resume players
last-minute players didn't have any
motivation to
to continue to study study chess and
they only
pushed it
they only took more energy and uh
inspiration to to prepare for the
candidates when they
they knew already the dates uh of the of
the second half
yes so the game number three is guilty
against one how giri
will have a white pieces and if you want
to win this tournament
this is a very good moment for him to
show or to show what what he can do
except after tweeting on and answering
on cscom tweets
also uh in the game uh the last game is
also
again dean clearing against washiela
graf uh i want to say that
ninja was actually one of the favorites
before the first
lap of the tournament uh one year ago he
he had amazing year but this panda
actually was very difficult for him
he was only one player who who was two
times in current in first time when he
came to the tournament
from china his first uh stood two weeks
in russia in
moscow region and then when he was
coming back he spent also two weeks in
the some special place
uh just to let him go to go home and
he played the tournament much lower than
everybody expected and i think tomorrow
it's also the moment for him to show
what he can
because he's is one of their top five
players on my opinion
and uh for maxim it will be definitely
the tough day of
after he lost today and tomorrow to meet
the team player and
it's not easy not easy at this moment
but
dean i think this is what we all wanted
to see this is uh
we want to see exciting days we want to
see uh
very interesting games and uh also i
would like uh
to see you of course in the studio so
i'm very glad
to have this day uh to have this day
such a tournament
and and such games yes that was a that
was a very very nice
um that was a very nice
uh first first uh
coverage from from
from the round eight uh that was also
the first day we
we worked together how did you enjoy it
did you enjoy it uh well i feel that he
was a little bit
nervous uh it seems like it was your
first time
was that on the chair stream was it
right
what was your worry about wait wait let
me see my script
i've prepared something for this one i
prepared something
well guess what let us let our fans
decide who is better at this
yes please uh write the comments uh
don't forget to put likes
and come back tomorrow for our live
live breakdown studio on the candidates
chels tournament together
together with woman grandmaster dina
belinker
and grandmaster ernesto and our kiev as
ernesto said do not forget to
like share and of course subscribe
to the channel
[Music]
you